We're asked to compute
347 divided by 5.
So let me just rewrite
it like this.
We have 347-- let me
write it bigger.
We have 347, and we want to
divide it by-- so I'll put the
division sign here, maybe the
long division sign, depending
on how you want to view it,
and then I'll put the 5 in
blue-- divided by 5.
So the first thing we do is
say does 5 go into 3?
No, it doesn't, so let's
add another digit here.
Does 5 go into 34?
Well, 5 times 6 is equal to 30,
so that goes into it, and
if we go above that, 5 times 7
is equal to 35, so that's too
big, so it goes into
34 six times.
Because if we went with 7,
we would've gotten 35.
That's too big.
So 5 goes into 34 six times.
6 times 5 is 30-- we
saw that right over
there-- and we subtract.
34 minus 30.
Let me do this in a new color.
Well, 4 minus 0 is 4.
3 minus 3 is just 0, and then we
can bring down this 7 here.
5 goes into 47 how many times?
Let's see, 5 times 8 is equal to
40, so that would work, but
let's see if we can go
in even more times.
5 times 9 is equal to 45.
That'll work.
That's still less than 47.
Then we have 5 times 10 is
50, so this is too big.
So we want to go with 5 times
9 is equal to 45, or 5 goes
into 47 nine times.
9 times 5 is 45, and then
you subtract again.
47 minus 45 is 2.
And then we're done.
There's nothing else
to bring down here.
One day, we'll learn about
dividing it into decimals and
getting some kind of a decimal
representation, but we're not
going to worry about
that right now.
We have nothing left
to bring down.
So 347 divided by 5 is 69.
It is 69.
It is equal to 69, but it
doesn't go evenly into 347.
There's something left over.
There's a remainder.
There is a remainder
right here.
So it equals 69, and sometimes
you'll see it written as
remainder 2, or sometimes
it's a capital R.
Sometimes people will write out
the word "remainder." So 5
goes into 347 sixty-nine times,
but you're going to
have 2 left over.
Or another way to think about
it is 5 times 69 is 345, so
you're always going to have
2 left over in this
circumstance.
So that is our answer.